Hey there smart less listeners, it's Kelly Rippa. Remember hearing that Matthew McConaughey and Woody Harrelson might be brothers or that Rob Lowe briefly had a fling with Demi Moore? Lucky Rob. You can hear it all and much more on my podcast, Let's Talk Off Camera with Kelly Rippa. Every Wednesday I get to ask the questions that I really want to know and talk to friends like Andy Cohen, Carol Burnett, Seth Meyers, Goldie Hawn, and so many more. It's fun, it's honest, and the best part, it's off camera. And believe me, that's when you get the good stuff. One of my favorite conversations was with the legendary Coleman Domingo. We talked about his longstanding friendship with Lenny Kravitz, his full circle moment with Oprah, and the
嘿，SmartLess的听众们，我是凯莉·里帕。还记得马修·麦康纳和伍迪·哈里森可能是亲兄弟，或者罗伯·洛曾与黛米·摩尔有过一段短暂恋情的消息吗？罗伯真幸运。你可以在我的播客《Let's Talk Off Camera with Kelly Ripa》中听到这一切以及更多内容。每周三，我都有机会问出我真正想知道的问题，并与安迪·科恩、卡罗尔·伯内特、塞斯·梅耶斯、歌蒂·韩等许多朋友交谈。这很有趣，很真诚，最棒的是，这是在镜头之外进行的。相信我，那才是你能听到干货的时候。我最喜欢的对话之一是与传奇人物科尔曼·多明戈的交流。我们谈到了他与兰尼·克拉维茨的长期友谊，他与奥普拉的圆满时刻，以及
unbelievably romantic way Coleman met his now husband. Here's a little taste of that love story. So tell me the story about how you met your husband because it doesn't sound real. You know, because it doesn't feel real, to be honest. Tell me. First of all, we're celebrating our 10-year wedding anniversary in two days. Amazing. Thank you.
科尔曼与他现在的丈夫相遇时那段不可思议的浪漫方式。这里先让你尝尝这段爱情故事的滋味。那么，告诉我你是怎么遇到你丈夫的，因为这听起来太不真实了。你知道，老实说，因为这感觉就不真实。告诉我。首先，我们两天后就要庆祝结婚10周年纪念日了。太棒了。谢谢。
Thank you. But we met almost 20 years ago. Next year will be 20 years. We literally met in the Stone Ages of technology. And I say that because I was really minding my business. One night I was living, I lived in New York, but I went to Berkeley Rep to do a show. So on Sunday night, I decided to go to Walgreens to get a mask. I wanted to get like a Queen Helene mask
谢谢。但我们几乎是20年前认识的。明年就是20年了。我们真的是在科技的石器时代相遇的。我之所以这么说，是因为我当时真的在忙自己的事。一天晚上，我住在纽约，但我去了伯克利话剧团演出。所以周日晚上，我决定去沃尔格林买个面膜。我想买那种海伦皇后面膜
to like get my pores together. So I go in there and walking out of Walgreens was this beautiful, beautiful man with hair down past his shoulders and a lip piercing. And I was like, what? And he had the greenest eyes. I don't know, he just looked like something out of a fairy tale.
来护理一下我的毛孔。所以我走进去，从沃尔格林走出来的是一个非常、非常漂亮的男人，头发长过肩膀，还戴着唇环。我当时就想，什么情况？他有着最绿的眼睛。我不知道，他看起来就像童话里走出来的人一样。
And we just locked eyes. And I was just awestruck by it. So then I came back outside. I didn't even go inside. I came back out. And I'm looking at him, he's looking at me. He's with this girl, and this girl seems to be pissed off about something.
我们四目相对。我被他惊呆了。所以我又回到了外面。我甚至没进去。我又出来了。我看着他，他也看着我。他和那个女孩在一起，那个女孩似乎对什么事很生气。
But he keeps looking over at me. And I was on the phone with somebody who was just gabbing away. I said, okay, I need to go in the sky. I'm gonna talk to this guy And I finally hang up by the time I hang up He he and this girl there she's dragging him down the street down Shattuck Avenue in Berkeley And he keeps looking back at me and I raised my hand to say come back. He doesn't come back
但他一直看着我。我当时正在和某人通电话，那人一直在喋喋不休。我说，好吧，我得挂了。我要去和那个家伙说话。我终于挂断了电话，等我挂断时，他和那个女孩已经在街上走远了，她正拖着他沿着伯克利的沙特克大道走。他一直回头看我，我举起手示意他回来。他没有回来。
Mmm, and so I was like so then I'm really I was I'm gonna tell you the full story I was so kind of dazed about all this I go I go back outside and I think, will he come back? And I thought, well, maybe he felt the same way. I'm a romantic. Maybe he'll meet me back here next Sunday at eight o'clock if he felt the same way. So I put that away. Three days later, I'm trying to buy a used computer
嗯，所以我当时……我要告诉你完整的故事。我当时被这一切弄得有点晕头转向。我回到外面，心想，他会回来吗？我想，也许他也有同样的感觉。我是个浪漫主义者。如果他也有同样的感觉，也许他下周日八点会回来这里见我。所以我把这个念头放下了。三天后，我正试图买一台二手电脑
on Craigslist because I got a grant to help out with my writing. I was a struggling artist. I was on Craigslist for like a good hour, and then I was just staring at the home screen. And I remember reading all those Craigslist misconnections, and I thought, well, what if I wrote one of those? Oh my gosh.
在Craigslist上，因为我得到了一笔资助来帮助我的写作。我当时是个挣扎中的艺术家。我在Craigslist上看了好长一段时间，然后就盯着主屏幕发呆。我记得读过所有那些Craigslist上的“错失连接”，我想，如果我也写一个会怎样？天哪。
So I started just reading them, and then I get to the second page, third from the top, and I see it says, Saw Yacht Settle Walgreens Berkeley. I literally jumped the fuck up and I was like, get the fuck out of here. That's me. I click on it. I almost clicked on it like I was scared. I clicked it and he described me and my faux hawk because it was 20 years ago when I had
所以我开始阅读它们，然后翻到第二页，从上往下数第三个，我看到上面写着：在伯克利沃尔格林看到的那个家伙。我简直跳了起来，心想，开什么玩笑。那是我。我点击了它。我点击的时候甚至有点害怕。我点开了，他描述了我，还有我的莫霍克发型，因为那是20年前，我当时留着
a faux hawk. He described me to a T and said, I'm sorry, we were lost and my friend was rushing off. I hope this finds you. Apparently, he posted that just an hour before. He tried to post it three times before, but it didn't go up until like an hour before. I reached out to him by email. We agreed to meet up two days later in San Francisco at this bar named Dalva, called Dalva. I go in there. We agreed to meet up two days later in San Francisco at this bar named Dalva, called Dalva. I go in there, we have a beautiful night.
莫霍克发型。他把我描述得一模一样，并说：“对不起，我们迷路了，我的朋友走得很急。希望你能看到这个。”显然，他就在一小时前发布的。他之前尝试发布了三次，但直到一小时前才发布成功。我通过电子邮件联系了他。我们约定两天后在旧金山一家叫Dalva的酒吧见面。我走进去。我们约定两天后在旧金山一家叫Dalva的酒吧见面。我走进去，度过了一个美好的夜晚。
I'm trying to be a good boy. He wants me to go home with him. I'm like, ah, no, no, no, no, I'm trying, I'm trying to, you know. You know. Make him earn it a little bit more. Yeah. Ha ha ha ha.
我试图做一个乖孩子。他想让我跟他回家。我说，啊，不，不，不，不，我正在努力，我正在努力，你知道的。你知道的。让他多争取一下。是的。哈哈哈哈。
Ha ha ha ha. Or I'm trying not to be a whore. Yes, exactly. Yes, I got it. I'm with you, I understand. You understand. So I was like, you know, I'm trying to to be a whore. Yes, exactly. Yes, I got it. I'm with you. I understand. You understand. So I was like, you know,
哈哈哈哈。或者说我尽量不让自己显得太随便。是的，没错。是的，我明白了。我和你一样，我理解。你理解。所以我当时想，你知道，我尽量
I'm trying to practice some good behavior. So I was like, well, how about this? I'll go home with you, but we can just, let's just cuddle tonight. Cause I really, something about him I really liked. I just really liked him. And so we're laying there and I couldn't sleep. It's about four in the morning.
我试图表现得体一点。所以我说，那这样好吗？我跟你回家，但我们今晚就只是拥抱一下。因为我真的，他身上有些东西我很喜欢。我真的很喜欢他。所以我们躺在那里，我睡不着。当时大约是凌晨四点。
And I just say this quietly. I didn't think he was awake or anything. I just said, I think I love you, and you're about to change my life. And he heard me, but he didn't say anything. And so we've been together ever since. Like when I tell you God and then get this here, here's the coda to the story. There's another there's a coda. We believe we were supposed to meet two or two years before because we started to the story. There's a coda. We believe we were supposed to meet two years before
我轻轻地说了一句。我以为他没醒或者什么的。我只是说，我想我爱你，你即将改变我的人生。他听到了，但他什么也没说。从那以后我们就一直在一起。当我告诉你上帝……还有，听着，这是故事的尾声。还有另一个，有一个尾声。我们相信我们本该在两年前就相遇的，因为我们开始……故事的尾声。我们相信我们本该在两年前就相遇的
because we started to find out, I was like, oh, my agent is in the building on Gary Street in San Francisco. Oh, really? I used to work on Gary Street. I used to work for Gucci. I was a tailor at that same building. I was like, really? Oh, yeah. What floor was it on? I said, my agent was on the sixth floor. He was like, oh my God, I worked on the fifth floor. And then we both remembered this one moment. To hear the rest of the story, to find out what happened, go listen to the episode and be sure to check out the other great conversations I've had with folks like Rob Lowe, Jeremy Renner, Tyler Perry, Selma Hayek, Alec Baldwin, my own daughter Lola,
因为我们开始发现，我说，哦，我的经纪人在旧金山加里街的那栋楼里。哦，真的吗？我以前在加里街工作。我以前在古驰工作。我在同一栋楼里做裁缝。我说，真的吗？哦，是的。是在哪一层？我说，我的经纪人在六楼。他说，天哪，我在五楼工作。然后我们都想起了那一刻。想听故事的其余部分，想知道发生了什么，去听这一集吧，一定要看看我和罗伯·洛、杰瑞米·雷纳、泰勒·派瑞、萨尔玛·海耶克、亚历克·鲍德温、我自己的女儿萝拉等人的精彩对话，
and so many more. So download my podcast, Let's Talk Off Camera with Kelly Ripa, wherever you get your podcasts. You're gonna love it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有更多。所以，无论你在哪里收听播客，都请下载我的播客《Let's Talk Off Camera with Kelly Ripa》。你会喜欢的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。